hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review i have another product
review for you it's somewhat of an
unusual product from company cord
called the hugo m scaler
as the name kind of indicates it takes
digital input and outputs digital
audio
but it
is able to up sample it to a higher
sample rate either twice as much four
times as much or 16 times as much and
the idea is that the larger that number
the better it can make your music
sound
and company's claim to fame is that
this up sampling uses very very large
filter tabs and
i'm not going to get into details of
what that is right this second although
i'll show you some measurements and talk
a little bit about it
um
there is a
theoretical benefit in that you can make
a filter sharper
in response
if you have more taps and company claims
that the more taps they add the better
the sound fidelity is and
even though the difference can be
measured
down in i don't know 300 db or so so
very very incredibly small numbers
but anyway our job is to forget about
what's inside the box and say well you
know how does it work as as a solution
as a black box if you will
um it's a typical of uh cored products
with these
globe
plastics that light up different colors
let me get that
it's quite heavy in this instantiation
of it and i usually detest the interface
because you have to memorize what the
buttons do and on top of that what the
different colors mean and so forth here
there are a lot of them and that makes
it easier to learn what the buttons do
and so i didn't have as much difficulty
although i had to memorize the sample
rate conversion colors at the beginning
i had to keep looking at the manual to
know what you know red and blue and and
white were so
you know not the best thing in the world
and certainly at
nearly six thousand dollar price i
expect to have see a display on this uh
and showing me what it's doing as
opposed to trying to memorize
uh what these buttons are
um
the
if you look at the back of it you can
get a better picture of what it does uh
it has a set of digital inputs so you
can have two different uh
spdif in the form of bnc inputs
typically you see rca jacks in here but
more correct way to implement this is
using bnc as far as impedance you have a
couple of toslink inputs and nicely it
has a usb interface so if you plug this
in into a computer this actually acts
like a audio device even though its
output is only digital so you still need
a dac to connect to the downstream and
the dac you can connect with a toslink
again optical or you can connect with a
coax
as a single channel a speediff but you
can also connect it using dual cables
within proprietary uh scheme that cord
has come up with that only works with
their own dax and if you did that you
can way exceed the spec for spdif all
the way up to 768 kilos
now the
member was kind enough to loan me a
cord hugo 2 also
that is compatible with those dual
cables so i managed to go ahead and test
the full capabilities of the product
with cord's own decks but the product is
standalone it can also work with
existing dax and i'll show you the
results of that
um very fancy cabling was supplied with
it two nordos
tier two cables each one of those is
eighteen hundred dollars so i had
sixteen hundred dollars worth of cables
alone
then you and the uh hugo ii doesn't have
bnc or even rca inputs it has a 3.5
millimeter connector so you have to have
a y connector from that to to this so
a lot of pieces a lot of moving parts in
here but bear with me we'll get through
it
um a little bit about operation of a
device whenever you have a digital
processing device you have an
opportunity for things to overflow as
you apply math and everything so
typically what you do is that you lower
the levels to allow some headroom for
the math and
then you do your processing there the
problem with that that is that now your
output level is lower and you actually
lose some dynamic range
um to make a b testing of all the
different sample rates uh
easier uh cord has implemented a
pass-through mode where you it's the you
know one of the four different modes
when you push that and this button goes
uh oh sorry you couldn't see my mouse
this button goes red
and uh but the pass-through is not a bit
perfect uh pass through in that it still
does this level adjustment uh which is
nice because then when you cycle through
the other modes that actually do the up
sampling then the levels don't change so
it makes it very easy to do a b testing
that way so i appreciated that but again
remember you are losing some dynamic
range as soon as you do that but
whatever amount is if
that thing is two and a half three db
and how much you take out is how much
you lose in dynamic range uh turns out
the situation is actually worse and
we'll get into that
okay
so first thing i did was just look at
the basic quality of digital connections
on this the audio precision apx 555 that
i use
has a special
option where you can look at the
jitter on a digital
audio interface including spdif
and so i ran that first what i did was
to get a baseline and get you familiar
with it
the audio analyzer has both input and
output uh spdif so i connected them with
the same cable i used later on with the
cord
and i measured what its input and output
uh measure itself you know how much
jitter comes out and i'm running a
special test signal called the j-test
which i won't go into but this spikes
are correlated with that so this green
line is the baseline best case
performance of this of the measurement
system itself
um
and then i routed the signal through uh
m scaler and tested it in either
pass-through or 2x or 4x uh
on this thing and i was shocked to see
this much increased
uh
noise floor over here and uh
not only do we have this increased noise
flow but now these jitter components are
actually now riding on top of uh of the
increased noise you would think if it's
just a noise went up it would just swamp
these uh jitter components but it didn't
it also raised those
so
this is shocking because companies
tend to build over engineer products
in ways that typically don't have value
but they don't do any harm in this case
is under-engineered in that it is
clearly adding noise and this is either
jitter random jitter noise or
quantization noise meaning the internal
precision
and or the dithering that it does and
i'll get into what the other is in a
minute um has robbed you you know some
amount of performance now we're still
talking very small numbers if you look
at the scale in here this is one pick a
second so this thing has gone from you
know one or two bigger seconds now to 12
or 15 picoseconds so it's not audible
stuff but you know for a company that
prides itself on engineering and
precision of his filtering it seems
quite sloppy work i can get a hundred
dollar
usb to uh speed of converter and it will
perform better than this and by the way
this is with usb going into
m scalar and i'm testing the coaxial
output but what happens if we take the
uh clean signal out of my analyzer or in
spdifs and output spdif so speed to
speed of converter the problem gets far
worse now look at what's happening here
we still have our uh you know much
raised random noise floor but we now
have this really correlated spikes
they're very very very very distinct
one of them is now shooting up to almost
two nanoseconds in here so about i don't
know a thousand times higher level if
you spit if input
that's just what's just shocking to me
so i went to the dashboard view where i
the analyzer also has a jitter uh meter
and i asked it to show me the jitter
when i'm i'm not using the m scaler and
this is the as low as it can show by the
way it's showing 214 picoseconds it's
actually much lower than this but
the meter doesn't have low resolution
but when i
ran the same signal through m scalar
look at this now we have four
nanoseconds every nanosecond is a
thousand picoseconds so we have about 20
times more jitter coming out of m scalar
than without
and
it's just shocking to me i mean this is
almost a six thousand dollar digital
device it doesn't have any analog
circuits in it doesn't have things that
normally will be difficult and
challenging to get right with precision
you know all this guy do send out a
clean signal over a spdif
and it's clearly polluting the input
signal um
now dax are very good at filtering these
kinds of noise so
as a practical matter you won't hear it
but
hey if you're going to sell me an
expensively engineered product and
you're selling it on precision
then it better
not you know destroy the input as far as
fidelity of signal and a lot of
audiophiles go chasing you know cables
and all kinds of tweaks to reduce jitter
and here we are
you know an audiophile tweak device that
is just
putting copious amounts of
jitter in here
just to give you context about 500
picoseconds is equivalent of jitters
equivalent to one bit of a 16-bit audio
so this is
like eight times more than that so
you've clobbered two or three bits of
16-bit audio
if you can't filter this jitter so even
though it's a small number its impact
can be fairly large
if you still have doubt visualizing what
this looks like if i look at the jitter
spectrum of the analyzer output before
it goes to m scalar look at what it
looks like it's basically random noise a
little ticks in here and there now look
at what happens when i run it through m
scalar you can clearly see a pattern in
here which means that noise is bleeding
from rest of the device onto the coax
output that's coming out of it
it's just unacceptable i know the
company and the designer rob watts has
an audio precision analyzer just like i
have
you would think he would have measured
this and
just for sake of good engineering trace
this down and fix it
i don't think it's a complicated problem
to fix
but
maybe he didn't measure it maybe he
doesn't know how to measure or care
about jitter is puzzling to me uh you
know it's it's just totally out of
character and
it just doesn't make sense in this class
of device hey if it was a 500 device i
expected to not do this let alone a 5
000 device
so this is just looking at fidelity of
that coax signal and by the way all as i
mentioned all of depending on it doesn't
matter which mode and up sampling you
use you're going to be saddled with this
jitter so it was not dependent on up
sampling or not up sampling it's just
physical layer issues with the interface
that it has
next test i did was connect the
m scalar to topping
these 70s before i show you that let me
show you its performance standalone
and
[Music]
driving it with coax because that's how
i'm going to drive it with the m scaler
and you can see that incredibly good
performance it has the only distortion
it has is well below threshold of
hearing and you know cyanides 118 db
it's just fantastic now note that it
outputs 5 volts by itself
now i run the same signal through m
scalar
and let's see what happens now the
output drops to 3.6 volts as i said it
tries to clear uh create a headroom in
there we still don't pass through on m
scalar which means that it's not up
sampling anything all it's doing is
changing the level
in theory but look at what happened to
our cyanide it dropped like a rock
from 118 down to 96. again i have the m
scalar in pass-through mode the only
thing is documented to do is change the
level no way i should be losing 25 db of
performance
and why are we losing that performance
is because of this spectrum
look at all this spikes that are here
that we did not have before
to the left of our tone there was
nothing completely blank now we have
this oddball thing at around 310 320
hertz
what's the cause of that i mean that
doesn't relate at all to the signal i'm
testing or anything these other spikes
are not harmonics of one kilohertz this
one is not two kilos it's like 1.6 or
something they're all at odd multiples
of each other but not related to the uh
to the main tone which is just one
kilohertz
your guess is as good as mine so i did
this i actually retested this two or
three times i've connected direct and i
got this performance up here
as i expected and i go through m scalar
in bypass mode
and it's doing this to the dac it just
makes no sense
it's creating some kind of
incompatibility
overdriving the inputs on
topping d70s
whatever it's doing the variables the m
scale are doing this so
even though the company says you can use
this box without the dax i'll caution
you in doing anything like that because
god knows what your dac is going to do
here we've lost performance all the way
down to 16 bits now 25 db of hard-earned
performance in the design of the attack
has been thrown out the window
so
you know this was very unexpected you
get a box like this if you're very you
know skeptical you can say it does
nothing well it's doing serious harm in
here and it's not because of jitter by
the way as i explained jitters filtered
out and these are not jitter components
on this deck
so
um
let's go ahead and switch dax now use
company's own dac hugo 2
and
same same pass-through mode we see that
it drops its output i'm not showing you
it's full output but it also takes its
output from 2 volts down to 1.5 volt but
now none of those problems are apparent
clearly the companies tested it with
their own dax
and there are no issues there
but
you know with the just a random deck
that i picked
it was uh clearly doing some damage
there
so now it says the next question is okay
with their own dac nothing bad happens
but is there something good happening
so i went ahead and applied 2x up
sampling so my
44.8 for 44.1 kilohertz is now 88
kilohertz and then 4x sam up sampling
which is 176 kilos and if you compare
these together you see that up sampling
buys you nothing in here basically we
have run to run variations in sign ad
and
the distortion distortion's the same you
see the same two spikes in here same two
spikes over here the noise floor not a
hairs out of place on this thing now you
might say whoa you know maybe only at
this dual cable mode is is where the
magic is all right well let's look at
the dual cable mode and this is a dual
cable mode so it's running at
760 kilohertz whatever that is 16 times
times 44.1 and guess what same two
distortion spikes
same noise same output level same
frequency
it just nothing's changed nothing is
changed the dac
still thinks it's being fed the original
signal if you will um with this test
though
so uh testing all three modes
2x 4x and 16x in our dashboard view
there's absolutely absolutely no
difference in in distortion noise or
anything else that you would think that
this you know magic is happening and
i'll have more tests uh to show you but
let's step back and say is it doing what
it says it's doing on the label and the
label says i use these very very large
tab filters
which by the way caused a lot of delay
so it has this hokie video mode that's
supposed to reduce that delay
uh if you watch video and it only works
for 48 kilohertz so it's not a good
solution but anyway
indeed it is doing that so if i
go back to the topping d70s and test it
with its own standard slow filter by the
way this is 48 kilos not 44.1 so i
forgot to change the title we see that
24 kilohertz should be our
cutoff thing but
most stack filters are lazy in that
regard so it goes up to 26 kilohertz
before
it you know uh
gets to his full attenuation when i
switch to 2x or 4x mode and look at what
i get by the way the bypass is you know
the same although there's a noise
increase in him which i'll get back to
when i go to 2x and forex look at what
happened i do get the sharp filter as
promised so yes it is giving me the more
perfect uh reconstruction filter that a
dac requires at half the sampling rate
so it's at 48 kilos we go to 24
so it is doing that but look at what
happened here the noise floor has
sharply increased this is the noise
floor of the dac by itself
when it's being dragged but when as soon
as i run the signal through
um m scalar whether i'm in bypass mode
or 2x mode or forex mode
i've now lost a good bit of uh
of noise floor over here so the device
is clearly adding noise now this is the
analog output i'm no longer showing you
a jitter spectrum which i showed you
before this is a true analog waveform
that would go through amplifiers and
will arrive at your ears um and we've
lost that and that noise floor now is
it's not impressive at all so we're got
i don't know 80 to 890 db of of uh noise
reduction i mean attenuation which is
poor if i had a dac and i tested this
filter and only had this much
attenuation
i would give it a thumbs down
so it's not good you want to get a high
performance stack needs to really filter
out the stuff not let them all let all
the junk through
to infinity at this uh raised floor uh i
should say that somebody posted a stereo
file uh measurement of the same device
and their number over here is minus 120
and people said well you know your
measurement's wrong actually it's not if
you look at the stereo file they did not
zero out the reference so their
reference is minus 40 and then
attenuation is minus 120 subtracted two
from each other is only 80 db so their
measurements are 100 consistent with
mine
so know that and not discuss that in the
measurements here
now something that could
change the tonality is frequency
response so i created a very high
resolution uh measurement where you can
see here a frequency response and it's
only half a db down on each side so this
is extremely zoomed and on the
frequencies i zoomed in to where the
transition band is you can see that in a
bypass mode the dac truncates to at
about 21.7 kilohertz so more than good
enough the audible bands about 20
kilohertz and most of us can't even hear
that so the dac didn't need any help but
as soon as we go through 2x 4x and 16
up sampling we see that we no longer
have that truncation because the dac is
operating at a higher sample rate so the
response actually keeps going but in the
audible band in here the dashed line is
the bypass mode and the 2x 4x and 16x
which i've tested here all of them have
basically the same output level they're
just maybe a you know 0.01 db difference
but i'm not worried about that so
there is no frequency response
difference which means that anybody who
claims the base is stronger the terrible
the
treble is is smoother and all that it's
all bogus because the tonality has not
changed one bit between
all four modes of of the scaling device
now i uh
one of the cool things about the
bypass mode as i mentioned is i bring
the level down so therefore it matches
it to what is being processed and with
the
um
hugo 2 dac uh i'm able to switch between
bypass and 2x without a glitch so as you
listen to music you just hit it and
instantly you're upsampled and there's
no interruption
and using that i did a bunch of
listening tests to my
standard tracks that i have and uh i use
my dan clark stealth headphone
which is in a four thousand dollar
headphone state of the artist for us uh
tonality and and uh um distortion and so
forth and
i i could not hear any difference
whatsoever uh as i was doing i mean it
was just as transparent as you could get
unfortunately when you go to 8x or 16 i
mean 4x or 16x
all of a sudden the dac would pause for
you know almost a second and then it
would start playing and that glitch is
enough to completely destroy your
short-term memory and invalidates any
comparison between bypass and those
higher higher modes
uh i wish there was true random access
between those and and also no
no delay i mean it would be nice if the
bypass mode also did a delay so that the
delay was constant and you never had the
glitch but it's not that way
now i know when i say well i didn't hear
anything people would say well you
wanted to not hear anything which is
fair uh so what i did was that i made
two captures with my rme adi 2 pro
fs and i've got those on on
dropbox they are linked in here and
they're blind in that i'm not telling
you which ones which there's sample one
and sample two um you're welcome to
listen to them to see if you can tell
the difference uh track's been up
they've been up since i did this review
yesterday and at least one person tried
to listen who was an advocate of m
scalar
and he couldn't hear the difference
so now the arguments come back that you
know how about 16x and everything
my simple answer is look bypass mode has
none of this magic filtering as soon as
go to 2x it's got a very high tap filter
if that difference that stark difference
has zero audibility
good luck in in you know making a case
of this thing being audible so samples
are there you're welcome to go listen to
him i thought about playing him here but
going through youtube
and compression is it's not a fair thing
so go and listen to them uh and see if
you can guess which one is which uh on
this thing
so where are we with this um we got a
box that i expected going into the
review to be doing is up sampling
more perfect than you possibly could
imagine
but probably not an audible difference
what i found was very disappointing that
it objectively
lowers the fidelity of the signal it's
got noise and jitter on on his bit of
output it gets better if you use usb as
an input because usb doesn't uh clocking
is different but if you use
coax input and coax output you're really
going to suffer uh on that um again
probably not an audible thing because
the dac any decent deck will filter that
but you know why why six thousand
dollars
it clearly raises the noise floor in its
filter and is filtering is very precise
in frequency but sloppy in amplitude
and the we need the amplitude to be more
perfect than we need the frequency to be
perfectly vertical uh on this thing and
so very disappointing from engineering
point of view now the company designer
rob watts uh answered
put out an answer to my review and
he quickly uh accepts and admits that
the noise is higher so what
uh you won't hear it it's like well
excuse me people buy these boxes live
and die by reducing noise and emi this
and jitter that and here you have noise
that's been generated and uh
first of all you didn't tell anybody uh
he's got uh
2876 posts in here uh waited for me to
find out that there's noise issues there
and where is the noise coming from
i explained that whenever you do math
you're going to have new set of results
if your
internal representation has higher
resolution than the data that's showing
the process as it should be otherwise
you lose a lot of accuracy
ultimately you still have to convert
things back to integer 24-bit pcm
samples coming out
and to do that conversion you can't just
truncate the higher resolution numbers
to get the low resolution you need to
apply what's called dither and dither is
just basically randomization of the bits
in a special way and if you do that
you don't get distortion but you get
extra noise
so right away there's a problem with
this architecture in that no matter what
this device does it will always always
add extra noise to your audio signal
that's a guarantee because
you know my measurements show it and the
designer says that they're adding uh uh
dither noise and they have to do this
it's not like he has the option of doing
not doing this but
he has to be upfront in that yes it's a
noisier output is what comes out don't
go assuming that this is from cord and
therefore is some perfect resampling
device the
signal processing fundamentals don't
allow it to not add noise now he says
the noise is high
higher than it should be because he uses
gaussian
noise as opposed to triangular dither
what this refers to is that let's say i
have one digit i have numbers from uh
from one to ten that have one decimal
point so uh
it's 3.4 right and three and you want to
convert 3.4 to to
just be threes you want common technique
you know about is uh rounding right
anything less than 0.5 you throw away
but anything over 0.5 you add one to it
that's actually a form of dither
and it's not a good form of diver
a much better method is to randomize
that lowered a bit
that you want to chuck and one of it is
a gaussian distribution which is this
bell-shaped thing that you may be
familiar with and he's saying that's
better than triangular dither which came
as quite a shock to me and anybody
knowing about signal processing triangle
dither his shape looks like this whereas
the other one looks it looks like a
bell-shaped thing
uh i hope anybody that ever deals with
dither is familiar with this paper from
professor lipschitz and
professor van di kui
from university of waterloo and canada
they are the duo
really know their math and signal
processing and written tons of papers
for the engineering society on this and
if there's
ever somebody you don't want to mess
with on dither is uh these these two
guys and indeed rob watts is messing
with them because they have a
seminal paper the paper that
demonstrated why you want to use
triangular pdf theater
versus gaussian
dither and right here you know if you
don't understand anything i've said says
this is better than gaussian dither
okay it produces a noise that's 1.2 db
less than gaussian case so
if you use triangular
dither you don't have to add as much
noise to the system remember i said you
have to add this noise so
that's better use the best case scenario
in here rather than the worst technology
in here now as as the professors tell
you is that the reason it doesn't get
used as much and by the way there's an
old paper today it's used all the time
it's because it takes more
complexity to generate those numbers
in computers it's a walk in a park every
audio workstation lets you apply tpdf
dither not a problem at all
but you know this product implements
everything inside an fpga and logics or
logic and costs money so
perhaps some cost cutting was was
involved but there's no question that
gaussian dither is not as good uh both
of these dither systems
do the job as far as getting trading
distortion for noise but you definitely
want to use a triangular dither and
the proof is in the pudding i showed you
that there's a noise penalty in device
that it should not be
on this thing okay
so hopefully
got something out of it um
uh in my opinion this device does
nothing useful as far as sonic
improvements anybody who says otherwise
should go conduct a blind test like i
did have somebody test them blind do it
ten times if you get eight out of ten
just identify which is which uh on this
thing and absence of that
please don't come tell me you hear the
improvement yes i would also hear the
improvement if i bought a 6000 device
hooked it up with all the excitement and
paid more attention to what i'm hearing
all of a sudden i'm going to hear more
detail and soundstage and all the
classic things and
it seems like just about everything that
people think does something when it does
and comes back with the same thing of
more detail blacker backgrounds and
better sound stage so i should be clued
that that can't be true of everything
anyway i i you know the test the
objective test back what i just said and
while the objectively generates noise in
jitter i don't think that's a
degradation so i don't expect people to
be hearing that artifact and i did not
hear it either
but
in my opinion it's not well engineered
either so
it's a product sometimes you just have
to sit back and state it simply that
it's just it's not needed it's not an
odd it doesn't improve things for
your sound for audiophile and he
certainly doesn't make it 48 kilos or 44
kilos
music sound like a high-res music once
you take a high-res music and chop off
the spectrum
you can up-sample all you want but you
already threw out the information that
you can't recreate
certainly you can't recreate it like
this or we would all be watching dvds on
our 4k and 8k screens and saying we
don't need 4k uh you know blu-ray and
what have you um you know a lot of
people think up sampling gives you the
original it doesn't do anything like
that it's a simple filter algorithm
and it doesn't it never creates more
information yes there's some issues with
uh you know filter response in the dac
being different at low versus high but
remember this thing does add you know
its own poison to the uh signals uh path
on this thing okay and i can take you to
consensus of our forum see what how
people voted yeah 91
92 i think is not worth anything and uh
the few uh characters you know said that
that is great so uh i've always given
high marks to rob wild stacks i think
they're over engineered and expensive
but you know i do recommend them so it's
not an issue of course this one just
unfortunately doesn't do anything useful
other than uh
take out a chunk of change out of your
bank account okay see you in a future
video bye-bye